مخاوف جديه تاب رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو من عصيان محتمل داخل
اروقه الجيش فيما الاحتجاجات ضد تعديل خطه
النظام القضائي تدخل الاسبوع الحادي عشر
ورئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيامين
نتنياهو يقول ان البعض يطالب باغلاق الطرق
والعصيان وسفك الدماء في الشوارع والحاق
الاذى بشخصيات العامه مشددا على ان
الحكومه لن تقبل بالفوضى والعنف من اي
جانب متوقعا من رئيس الاركان والرؤساء
الاجهزه الامنيه ان يقاوموا العصيان بقوه
كما اعلن عشرات الطيارين الحربيين ومشاغري
طائرات من دون طيار انهم لن يمثلوا في
خدمه الاحتياط خلال الاسبوعين المقبلين كي
يتمكنوا من المشاركه في المظاهرات ضد خطه
اضعاف جهاز القضاء وفق قولهم طبعا بدورها
اعلنت المحكمه العدل العليا الاسرائيليه
عن منع وزير الامن القومي اتمار بن غفير
من اعطاء تعليمات عمليه للشرطه خصوصا
اثناء الاحتجاجات ضد الحكومه واكدت
المحكمه ان هذه التوجيهات ضروريه من اجل
تجنب النزاعات في المستقبل كما انها تجنب
التوجيهات السياسيه للشرطه خلال حدث لا
يزال جاريه